اهلا بكم سواء بتدخلها العسكري او
بمبادراتها الدبلوماسيه بشان الازمه
السوريه فرضت موسكو مرحله جديده على
الاطراف المعنيه بالصراع الدائري في بلاد
الشام ذاك ما بدا جليا في مفاوضات استانا
التي افضت الى اتفاق بين روسيا وتركيا
وايران على اليه لتثبيت ومراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار بسوريا غير ان التناغم بين البلدان
الثلاثه الذي قالت الخارجيه الروسيه انه
يثبت وجود عمل بناء مشترك في الملف السوري
لا يخفي ما بين هذه الدول من خلافات في
المواقف والادوار وقد باتت تترقب ما يمكن
ان يضيفه تنصيب دونالد ترامب رئيسا
للولايات المتحده من معطيات طارئه ليس
اقلها اهميه طرحه الداعي الى اقامه مناطق
امنه لحمايه المدنيين بسوريا من يوافق ومن
يرفض من يمول ومن يشارك في التنفيذ مزيد
من التفاصيل في تقرير مريم
ابيش ما بعد استان وتنصيب ترامب رئيسا في
الب الابيض من يمسك بخيوط الملف السوري
بالاحرى من الحاضر في الحرب والسلم ومن
الغائب ومن الحاضر الغائب لم يعد سرا ان
ثمه اعاده توزيع ادوار وتموضع مع استمرار
روسيا في اداء دور البطوله شبه المطلقه
وصل الامر بحلفه نظام دمشق وخلال ايام
العسل مع انقره الى عرض مسوده دستور جديد
لسوريا تلغى فيه كلمه العربيه بعد
الجمهوريه وفي بند اخر جعل تغيير حدود
الدوله السوريه ممكنا عبر الاستفتاء العام
بند غير مريح بل مخيف لمن يخشون على تفكيك
سوريا الدور الروسي المزدوج عسكريا
ودبلوماسيا مرشح للازدياد في ظل اداره
ترامب عكس الرئيس السابق اوباما فان ترامب
عازم على المضي قدما في مساله انشاء مناطق
امنه استنادا لمسو حصلت عليها وكاله
رويترز فقد طلب الرئيس الامريكي الجديد من
وزاره الخارجيه وضع خطه لاقامه مناطق امنه
في سوريا والمناطق المحيطه بها في غضون 90
يوما بالتعاون مع وزاره الدفاع لا يعرف هل
سيلجا الى اصدار قرار رئاسي ام سيعود الى
السلطه التشريعيه المهم بالنسبه له قطع
الطريق امام تدفق اللاجئين السوريين على
اوروبا وبدرجه ثانيه امريكا ما يهم الرجل
في الملف السوري هو جزئيه المهاجرين الذين
لا يرحب بهم المناطق الامنه بالنسبه
لتركيا تعني حمايه حدودها من تنظيم الدوله
ومنع قيام كيان كردي على ابوابها انشاء
هذه المناطق امر مكلف جدا اذا تم دون قرار
من مجلس الامن لانه يرتبط ايضا بفرض حضر
للطيران السؤال الاهم كم منطقه امنه يمكن
ان تقام ومن سيكون المسؤول عن كل واحده
انن تكون تمهيدا مؤلما لمشروع تقسيم سوريا
بين مفيده واخرى بلسم حتى الان اين ايران
كل ذلك كلام المسؤولين في دافوس وطهران
واستانا عن العمل من اجل جمع شمل السوريين
ووقف الحرب يندرج في اطار الدعايه
الاعلاميه لا غير وفق ما يرى كثيرون في ظل
التقارب الروسي التركي وتحديد الدور
الامريكي عند قضيه المناطق الامنه لتامين
سياسات ترامب الرافضه للاخر اي دور سيسب
طهران
اكثر هل يمكنها تحقيق المعادله الصعبه وهي
الحفاظ على الود الروسي وضمان الطريق
والسلاح لحزب الله اللبناني مهما كان
الثمن وعدم الاصطدام مع الولايات المتحده
حليفه اسرائيل واستمرار الهدنه او
المهادنه مع تركيا وحلفائها الخليجيين
الثابت الوحيد في هذه الحرب الداميه هي
ماساه المواطن السوري الذي يتلاعب الاخرون
بمصيره بمباركه نظام قائم على
الاطلال ينضم الينا من باريس خطار ابو
دياب الباحث في المعهد الدولي للدراسات
الجيوسياسيه وكذلك معنا في الاستديو
الدكتوره فاطمه امادي الباحثه في الشؤون
الايرانيه بمركز الجزيره للدراسات اهلا
بكما ابدا معك سيد خطار ابو دياب في باريس
يعني يبدو الان ان كل الاطراف الدوليه
تسير نحو تنفيذ رؤيتها لحل الازمه السوريه
سوريا تقدم اليوم رؤيتها
السياسيه ومقترح للحل السياسي الولايات
المتحده تتحدث عن اقامه مناطق امنه وتركيا
تتحدث عن ضرب تنظيم الدوله تتحدث عن حدود
ولاجئين وربما معركه درع الفرات في اي
اطار يمكن قراءه كل هذه الادوار
واعاده تموضع هذه الاطراف الدوليه
جميعها تحياتي لك وللسيد فاطمه و
للمشاهدين
الكرام بالطبع النزاع السوري هو اول نزاع
اقليمي دولي متعدد الاقطاب في القرن
الحادي والعشرين وكما ذكرتم هناك ادوار
متعدده لكن في منعطف ما بعد حلب يبرز
الدور الروسي كدور اساسي وهناك عندما نطلع
على ما تم توقيعه حول طرطوس وحول حميميم
كاننا امام انتداب روسي على الاراضي
السوريه بموافقه والطبع من النظام ولكن
هناك ايضا الدور المهم لايران على الارض
مع تمركزها ومع توقيع عده معاهدات في اهم
القطاعات الاقتصاديه وكانها هي تمسك
بالحلقه الاولى بالنظام وبلعبه بالرغم من
هذا الدور الروسي المركزي من فوق الذي
يحاول فرض دساتير ذكرتنا بما قامت به
الولايات المتحده في العراق لكن هذا لا
يعني ان الادوار الاخرى
مختفيه تركيا تحاول في الشمال السوري خاصه
الحفاظ على تربط ما بين دعمها وبين امنها
القومي وبين هاجسها من الاكراد وبالطبع
الولايات المتحده التي كانت غائبه خلال
الوقت الضائع تعود الان مع مساله المناطق
الامنه التي هي بحاجه لاستكمال في مطلق
الاحوال على ما ارى ليس هناك حتى الان من
استنفاد للوظيفه الس الجيوسياسيه لهذا
النزاع السوري اي هناك اذا ربما اراده
روسيه او رغبه روسيه في الاصراف مع تقديم
الدستور مع ما حصل في استانا مع كل هذا
الضغط من اجل ابراز هذا التحكم الروسي لكن
نحن امام تقاطعات قادتها روسيا في فتره
معينه مع اسرائيل من جهه مع تركيا مع
ايران لكن ذلك تم اما بموافقه امريكيه او
بغياب امريكي الان نعود لفصل جديد من
اللعبه بعد وصول اداره ترامب سيده او
دكتوره فاطمه يعني هل نحن كما يقول السيد
ختار ابو دياب امام فصول جديده في هذه
اللعبه لكن هل ما زالت ايران تمسك بالحلقه
الاولى بالحلقه الرئيسيه في هذه اللعبه
كما قال ايضا يعني موقف الولايات المتحده
واضح الان روسيا واضح وتركيا واضح اين
ايران من كل هذا هو ايران تمسك بحلقه مهمه
ومؤثره جدا في ال في الوضع السوري لكن
لكنها تراجعت يعني في الفتره الاخيره ومن
بدء الحديث عن الحل السياسي لا يمكن
الحديث عن ان ايران هي الممسكه بالحلقه
الاهم في الموضوع الروسي لكن في الوقت
ذاته يجب ان ننتبه الى ان ايران خلال خمس
سنوات على الارض فعليا يعني هي استطاعت ان
ان تصبح نافذه جدا في عدد من الملفات
السوريه يعني الجيش السوري واحد منها
الاقتصاد السوري ملف اخر حتى ديمغرافيا
على الارض ايران لديها نفوذ كبير و تدخلت
بشكل بشكل كبير لفهم الدول الايراني من
الممكن ان ننظر الى ردود الفعل الايرانيه
على بدايه الحديث عن او بدايه العمل لحل
سياسي في سوريا لا يوجد اجماع ايراني من
الممكن ان نرص يعني هي كانت حاضره على مدا
الخمس سنوات الماضيه لكن هل ما زالت حاضره
خاصه في الحراك السياسه الاخير ام انها
يعني مغيبه الحاضر الغائب ام مغيبه بالفعل
لا هي ليست ليست غائبه وليست مغيبه يعني
لا يمكن بهذه بهذا الشكل ان نقول على
الرغم من ان هناك اصوات ايرانيه تتحدث عن
ان ايران في في الحل السياسي الاخير او
السعي للحل السياسي دفعت الى الهامش لكن
لا يمكن الحديث ابدا عن ان ايران اصبحت
غير مؤثره في الملف السوري لانه يعني حتى
روسيا اذا ارادت ان تصل الى حل سياسي فهي
تعرف ان حل سياسي في سوريا لا يمكن ان يتم
الا بمشاركه ايرانيه لان الفعل الايراني
على الارض كبير ومؤثر ولا يمكن تجاوزه ا
سيد خطار ابو ديابي يعني برغم انه ا حاضره
منذ خمس سنوات روسيا حضرت منذ عام تقريبا
وربما على ما يبدو يعني حسمت الصراع
عسكريا على الاقل وكانت اللاعب الرئيس في
في في هذا الصراع الان هي تقدم مشروع
سياسي رؤيه سياسيه دستور ج مقترح لدستور
جديد في في سوريا الى اي مدى يمكن ان تفرض
هذا المشروع على الاطراف لا سما الدوليه
منها وتحسم المساله سياسيا كما عسكريا
بالفعل اذا كانت ايران حاضره منذ
بدايات الانتفاضه في درعا لكن ايضا روسيا
كانت حاضره لان الفيتو الروسي والتعطيل
الروسي قبل الدخول العسكري الروسي الكثيف
هو الذي اتاح صمود النظام الان ما ماذا
سيتم في مساله الحل السياسي نرى ان روسيا
تريد تركيز قاعده ملائمه لمصالحها هي تح
تحول ان تبني نوع من نظام يؤمن هذه
المصالح تطرح دستور تحاول ان يكون هناك
تاقلم ما بين الجانب الكردي بالغاء اسم
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه ومساله
الاقاليم الاتحاديه وتحاول ايضا اللعب على
مساله اعاده التكوين السوري عبر الغاء
الاكثريه بشكل عملي وهذا برايي بيت القصيد
وايران في هذا الموضوع حتى الان تبدو حذره
لم تقل كلمتها الاخيره تجارب التاريخ
علمتنا انه ما بين قوتين مؤثرين او قوتين
محتلين لا يمكن ان يكون التناغم الى اخر
حد في لحظه معينه يمكن ان يكون هناك قراءه
لمصالح اسرائيل من قبل الجانب الروسي لا
تتاقلم مع الرؤيه الايرانيه التي تركز على
الربط ما بين دمشق وطريق دمشق بيروت وحمص
وجوارها مع لبنان نحن امام اذا مساله
مقلقه مع مساله المناطق الامنه في توزيع
مناطق النفوذ ونلاحظ ان الطلب الايراني في
تركيز ميناء على المتوسط على غرب المتوسط
في منطقه النفوذ الروسيه لم نسمع حتى الان
تعليقا من موسكو اذا زمن التناغم والعمل
العسكري المشترك كان هناك تنسيق استراتيجي
ناجح لكن في زمن حصد المكاسب وفي زمن
تركيب سوريا الجديده
سنلمس والايرانيه ا في سياق متصل مشاهدينا
اشارت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال الامريكيه في
تقرير جديد لها الى ان ترامب اهل وزارتي
الخارجيه والدفاع الامريكيتين ثلاثه اشهر
حتى تعد خطه لتطبيق فكرته الداعيه الى
اقامه مناطق امنه للمدنيين بسوريا المزيد
عن هذا في التقرير و هذا التقرير في
النقاط
التاليه ول ستريت جورنال ذكرت ان خطه
ترامب تحمل في طياتها مشاركه اكبر للجيش
الامريكي في النزاع الدائري بسوريا بما في
ذلك القوه الجويه وقوات بريه امريكيه
واخرى من دول حليفه الصحيفه ذكرت بان
تركيا كانت ضغطت لسنوات على الاداره
الامريكيه السابقه لاقامه مناطق امنه
للمدنيين شمال سوريا دون جدوى وقالت صحيفه
ان فكره الرئيس الامريكي السابق باراك
اوباما كانت الخشيه من ان يوقع توفير
اماكن امنه للمدنيين بسوريا واشنطن في
دوامه لا تنتهي ول ستريت جورنال نبهت الى
ان الخبراء العسكريين يرجحون ان يعارض
البنتاجون خطه ترامب للمناطق الامنه اذا
كان الغرض الوحيد منها حمايه المدنيين
نعود الى ضيفين والى الدكتوره فاطمه معنا
هنا في الاستديو دكتوره فاطمه ايضا ايران
يعني تبدو ذره كما قال السيد خطار ولم تقل
بعد كلمتها الاخيره ولا يمكن ان يكون هناك
تناغم او ربما توامه ما بين قوتين على مدى
طويل نحن نعلم بان سوريا
هي ايران لديها مصالح كبيره في سوريا
تعتبرها ربما امتدادا
استراتيجيا
لها مهما تستطيع من خلالها ربما تسليح
حليفها في في لبنان حزب الله ما هي خيارات
ايران الان للحفاظ على هذا البعد
الاستراتيجي جي خيارات ايران تقوم على
اطاله امد المفاوضات بشان الحل السياسي
يعني ايران لن تسعى او لن تدفع نحو حل
سياسي سريع في سوريا هي معنيه باطاله امد
التفاوض وقد اشار عدد من مسؤوليها الى ذلك
ام ان انه سنكون جميعا امام يعني دورات من
المحادثات وهذا يعيد التذكير ب يعني
بعمليه التفاوض على الملف النووي وطولها
هذه مساله المساله الاخرى ان ايران قد
تضطر الى مراجعه علاقاتها مع الجوار من
الممكن ان نشهد يعني توجه مغاير نحو دول
الخليج والسعوديه على وجه التحديد اي ايضا
المساله بالنسبه لايران مرتبطه جدا بما
يعني بالسياسه التي سينتهجها ترامب تجاه
ايران تجاه الملف النووي لانه اذا استمرت
هذه اللهجه العدائيه فان ايران بالتاكيد
ستكون بحاجه شديده الى لروسيا للدفاع عن
عن الاتفاق النووي لكن بالتاكيد ان
المصالح الايرانيه والمصالح الروسيه لن
تلتقي في الحل السياسي في سوريا على ذكر
هذه الخطوه او هذه الفكره سيد خطار ابو
ابو ذياب يعني في اطار مرحله جديده تتشكل
الان وربما قدوم ترامب الى سده الحكم
والان عازه لوزارتي ب تكوين رؤيه لما
يتعلق بهذه المناطق الامنه توجه روسيا
الان لفرض
وتثبيت حل سياسي فيما يتعلق في هذه الازمه
الى اي مدى او او ما هو الحيز او المساحه
التي يمكن ان يسمح او تسمح بها هذه
الاطراف لايران في التحرك بشان الازمه
السوريه الاشارات الاولى الصادره عن ترامب
فيما يتعلق تركيز المناطق الامنه والطلب
من دول الخليج تمويلها او حتى
المشاركه في التحرك حولها سنرى ذلك لاحقا
وايضا كلام ترامب اليوم امام السيده ماي
رئيسه وزراء
بريطانيا بعدم الاستعجال في رفع العقوبات
عن روسيا كل ذلك يوحي بانه سيكون هناك
تفاوض لن يكون هناك سق على بياض كي تتحكم
روسيا لوحدها بالملف السوري وهذا ينطبق
ايضا على ايران وبراي ضمن التفاوض مع
روسيا سيكون هناك نوع من ابعاد ايران عن
التاثير وابعاد حزب الله عن التاثير في
سوريا عند ذلك سنرى اين يمكن ان يكون
الاصطفاف الروسي هذا هو تقديري تقديري
اننا نعم سنبدا مرحله جديده وان مرحله
التحكم الروسي المطلق بالورقه السوريه في
الايام الاخيره لويات اوباما وخلال الوقت
الضائع انتهت الان نعم شكرا لك من باريس
خطار ابو دياب الباحث في المعهد الدولي
للدراسات
الجيوسياسيه وشكرا لك دكتوره فاطمه صمادي
الباحثه في الشؤون الايرانيه بمركز
الجزيره
للدراسات